joining us now here on the rich eisen
show it's been a while since we've had
this met on he is
uh a pro football hall of famer and is
joining us uh on behalf of the
non-profit los angeles tourism and
convention board to promote uh los
angeles as a destination just as he has
learned it can be a pretty damn good one
not just for uh football life but the
life after football life a pro football
hall of famer joining us on the
mercedes-benz van phone line right now
eric dickerson how are you doing a.d hey
how you doing man it's good to chat with
you it's been a while good to talk to
you too i know it's been it's been a
good while i think i forgot about it no
i never i will never ever do that i will
never ever do that i'm just messing with
you how you doing no i know you tweeted
at me the other day because we did a
video about how uh you're gonna be
talking about asterisks with derek henry
and you laughed at me and uh now here we
are derek henry looks like he's not even
gonna play another snap this season
unfortunately yeah i i hate that
somebody you know i just did an
interview with the guy from
tennessee about derek kennedy you know
have come possibly having two thousand
yards you know breaking my record and i
you know i told him i said look i don't
think anyone would really want their
records broke but i said if if a guy's
gonna break it he'd be the guy to break
it right you know because you know he's
big i like big backs he's a big back
he's physical i mean you know people
talk about the running back is obsolete
in the national football league stage
and i don't believe it if you have the
right guy you know that's the guy you
use and i hate to see him get hurt so
you know i'd rather see him shatter that
record i don't see any player ever get
hurt because you know you play that
you play football you know how you know
how brutal that sport is then now the
guy who might be the one to replace him
adrian peterson at age 36
i mean what do you think is going
through his mind right now
eric well he ain't been hit in a while
so i don't think when they had that
first hit they'll be like whoa
you might not say it but you know
football is such a physical sport and ap
has been doing it for so long and he's
such a great player uh hey you know
you know he you get some chances they
can say to do it again i guess
so did you ever get a call after you
were done to say do you want to keep
running did you ever get any of those
no i could i couldn't reach because i
had i had a neck injury uh i couldn't
play again matter of fact that when i
when i saw the doctor uh you know the
doctor not at night with the football he
got outside the football team gave me
the real
real diagnosis he said he said that you
know if you keep playing football he
said one or two things going to happen
he said you could be paralyzing the neck
down or you're going down the field and
that was it i mean i was i was done i
could play again wow that's what they
told you that that's he told me that
that's what that's what that's what the
doctor told me you know the teens don't
tell you that but the doctor told you
yeah but dr dr watkins you know i really
appreciate that being honest with you
about that well i mean he's a guy that
would know i mean he's easy with no
right
he would know that's who peyton manning
saw for his neck you know i mean like
he's he's as preeminent as they possibly
can get but you never even got somebody
even just kicking the tire saying i know
that you're retired for a neck injury
but i'm just calling to make sure you
never get the call to make sure you know
you know richard you know for me i was
really down with it i really was i mean
i just you know as much as i loved
football when i first played it i mean
the sport that i grew up loving you know
at the end man i just
they made me despise the sports that i
love so much you know i talk about that
in my book that have coming out and you
know i loved football i loved everything
about i when i would come out in the you
know can close the football season i
could smell it in the air it was a smell
that you could just smell like
oh yes it's football time you know i
don't smell it anymore because i don't
i've just played so many years but you
know the sad thing is that uh like i
said a sport that i just love so much
adored so much at the end it was like
i'm just so done with this crap
just the the pain and the suffering
the pain the suffering you know the
politics go that goes along with it you
know the
you know the the sometimes the
jealousies being on on football teams i
won't forget when i was with the uh
without the rams that was such a
close-knit football team i mean
close-knit team
and when i got to the coast it wasn't
the same i mean yeah that was the first
time i've seen jealousy on the team like
players jealous of each other not just
me but any other players your name is in
the paper your money you make and that's
that's that's disheartening for me
because i think when you play a school
like football you play it because you
love it but you play up you know get
paid also but you play because you love
it and you want to you want to play well
you want to do well you want your team
to do well but it's just it was not like
that in indianapolis at that time
wow eric dickerson here uh on the rich
eisen show um now the rams uh are gonna
be the first step to take on the titans
without derrick henry and they've got
von miller there how do you think he
um he's gonna
i mean we all can sense what he can do
and we all know
that just by its own sense
it makes no sense that he's going to be
allowed to rush a quarterback with aaron
donald
and leonard floyd right i mean but
that's just
i can hear you laughing about it too
because that's what i did the other day
it's just you can't help but laugh
unless of course you're a quarterback
right
now i mean i was like right because i
knew when they they let up and kenny
young go i'm like okay something's up
because you know he's playing well for
us i'm like son of something's up i
think they want ernest jones to play uh
the young linebacker i think south
carolina they want him to play but i
just say something's up with that and
they said they were freed up some money
and uh you know we made that trade i'm
like wow i mean i feel like that is a i
think it's a great deal i really do i
mean i know he's for 32 years old but i
still know he can still play uh it gives
aaron dawn something to work with it
gives him something to work with that
you know he doesn't have to be the guy
like like when you're the guy all the
time and you know they they game plan
for you now they just can't game plan
for him so i think it's i think it's
going to be be great for him and and
also uh the los angeles rams well so who
do you think is the best team in the nfc
i mean i know you're you're locked in on
the rams and you're locked in and
watching everything else going on in
that division you saw what happened with
arizona against them and obviously with
aaron rodgers healthy uh an under center
or in shotgun for green bay you saw what
they did to the team that beat the rams
what do you think
you know you can't say i mean for me i
don't say who who's the team i think
who's the hottest team you know you got
a couple of teams that are really hot
right now you got the the packers the
green bay packers are really hard to
know and rogers not playing this because
protocol
uh you've got the arizona cardinals
which i'm really shocked about you know
because they are arizona you know i
teased my friend roy green i said y'all
arizona y'all can't beat nobody but you
know i got to give them credit they're
playing great football then you have the
rams that are playing very good football
and you know making this trade and also
just you know the the offenses seem to
be coming around and clicking with
matthew stafford um you know then you
have the tampa bay buccaneers i mean
it's just so many teams it's like who's
hot that day you know sometimes the best
team doesn't always win the game
sometimes they do you know it depends on
the turnover situation and also you know
i always go back to injuries injury is
always a big part of of any sport you
know just football basketball baseball
you know how the injuries play out so
right now i can't say who's the hottest
but i think those teams i just mentioned
in the nfc are pretty much the best
football teams mm-hmm and um so uh
you're you're calling in as part of the
uh la tourism that that stadium the rams
and charges play in is incredible it's
definitely something about when i say
that people come here to los angeles you
got to get off the plane you got to go
see it somehow somewhere that stadium
believe it or not i'm telling you rich
you have to see that stadium i mean i
went to see when they were building it
and you really couldn't get a feel for
it you know it's almost like a skeleton
like yeah you know it looks cool but you
know you're just not sure and i mean i
think everyone was was i mean not even
myself was comparing it to jerry's world
you know in dallas texas this state
and that's a beautiful stadium to have
in dallas because you know it's it's
jerry jones
but when you see the stadium here in los
angeles it's second to none i mean it's
nothing like it i mean it is just like
it's when you walk in i guarantee people
will go wow you just go wow man it is
massive
uh it's a beautiful stadium you know we
have you know you know we got the super
bowl here this you got the olympics
coming up there's just so much you know
that stadium can can do and you know
they have they have a uh i think a 6 000
seat amphitheater if they do concerts
i'd buy ponds so you know it's nothing
like that stadium right and then uh i
mean
what do you think of when you
when you walk into sofi and the rams
fans are in there and it's so damn loud
it literally is the loudest stadium in
the nfl and i've been in all of them and
i and i say this with the ultimate of
respect
to seattle fans and arrowhead fans i
mean it's like a rock concert my ears
are ringing after i come home from a
game at sophie
stadium like
when you're when you're you know back in
the day
this is the greatest home field
advantage the rams have ever had in los
angeles that's for damn sure
ever had what would you have done with
that crowd noise oh my gosh are you
kidding me
man i would have loved to play that
stadium that did being a young eric
dickerson oh you're coming on the field
with this with the the the
fan shouting your name and screaming for
you you're right i think it is the
loudest it not be like one of the
loudest stadiums in the national
football league uh people always talk
about the fans of la you know the fans
out there not good man we got great fans
here i mean it's like anything you want
your team to win and man what they're
they're excited about football i think
not just football but sports in general
here in l.a you got the dodge you got
the lakers you know you got the rams you
got you got the la charges so you know
this is a great time you know for la
sports right now okay yeah you've got uh
the college football playoff national
championship you got the us open the
major league baseball all-star games
coming of course the summer olympic uh
and the paralympic games in 2028 you got
the rose bowl sitting out here too
the la coliseum still home to the usc
it's pretty it's pretty amazing um
before i let you go eric i'm going to
ask you the question i'm going to put
you directly on the spot and i really
need an answer to this okay okay you
need an answer for it that's my wind-up
this is my wife okay uh
we don't have to we don't have to with
derek henry now unfortunately out for
the season this is not you know going to
happen this year um but
one day
if somebody comes up with yard number
2106
in an nfl regular season and it happens
in their 17th regular season game
should that mark have an asterisk next
to it eric dickerson no absolutely not
no it should not because
i always say this oj did it in 14 games
i did it in 15 with one extra game to go
so no it should not uh look to get 2 000
yards is an incredible feat it's very
hard i came close three other times and
could not get there so for sure not uh
and and i don't i would never say that i
mean you know me i'm honest i just like
i see it i know i want someone do i want
someone to break my record uh hell no
but if they break it they break it but
no if if they're doing 17 games so be if
they did in 17 games so 20 games it'd be
a little different okay okay
so there is a line there is a line
there's a there's a line there's a line
that is a line but this extra regular
season game folks shouldn't know oh you
know i did it so you did it in 15. so
there should be an asterisk if it's done
in 16.
exactly exactly
my name also i'm going to tell you
richard let me tell you the record that
i've always said that's going to last
the longest is my rookie rushing record
1808 yards is a rookie of 20 touchdowns
it's gonna be hard for any rookie to do
that because you know one thing you get
one shot at it one shot and that's it
man that was
that's those are ridiculous numbers eric
those are and 20 touchdowns on top of it
and
and 20 touchdowns so uh outside of
derrick henry now again that he is he is
hurt um the best running back in the nfl
is who for you
who man i you know i believe that i have
to i'd have to say z i mean really i i
think i think i think it's cj elliott i
mean i mean i know they haven't played
well in the last couple years i think
it's all him it's the cowboys offensive
line injuries and everything else but
i mean you'd have to go to zeke i mean
um
i can't think of yankees in in uh new
york he's been hurt saquon has now got
coveted too i know i mean you're talking
about a kid to me and i said this when
they drafted him i said i feel bad for
him because he's such a great player
so much talent i say but he'll they'll
never see his talent because he's in new
york and it's showing just what i said
and you hate to see that for a player
but i think that if it's a guy that
could do it
it would be him but he'll he'll never
get the chance because he's on that bad
football team so
it's it's not a new york thing it's just
the giants in their line is what you're
saying oh yeah yeah that's what it is
it's just it's just you know no no help
i mean let me tell you something being a
running back it's no fun walking to the
line of scrimmage and seeing an
eight-man front trust me that's still
fun
yeah and you're just sitting there going
oh man oh my god oh my gosh oh my god
would you see that about you you saw
that one
i saw that so much man i won't forget we
played the chicago bears in the nfc
championship game
i think the referee is up i think he's
trying to make tackles too
[Laughter]
so that was that nfc championship that's
right okay so you're you're there and
that's singletary right
that's the team you were going against
right come on
yeah
think about that i mean they and my my
friend richard then he told me sir he
said let me tell you what the game plan
was
don't let 29 beat us he said we he said
we had everybody at the line of
scrimmage i mean the safeties were right
behind the linebackers you're like they
were like when they weren't worried
about y'all passing the ball
so that was that was frustrating
it was it was the the 46 defense it was
really 46 people it wasn't
it looked like i'm telling you when i
say the referee was right there with the
safeties i'm like is he is he making
tackles too
eric let's do this more often i really
love chatting with you um i mean we're
local just like you obviously are uh
with the uh with with the committee um
here for los angeles and um and i
appreciate it thank you for the time
today thank you for having me you bet
that's uh the pro football you bet
that's the pro football hall of famer
eric dickerson on behalf of the los
angeles tourism and convention board
right here in l.a
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here